good grief said jotro Cujo as he his
grandfather Joseph joestar and the rest
of their Allied group of Stan users hid
from the light of day in the shadows of
a ruined building outside amorphous
semi-humanoid monstrosities roam free In
Search of Life how could this have
happened jotaro's family had been on
some Bizarre Adventures but this one was
proving to be the most bizarre of all
the sun now designated
scp-001 was burning with intense bright
red light and an anomalous level of heat
it beat down on the world below like an
evil and sadistic god of the desert the
entire world was at the mercy of these
oppressive solar rays and high
temperatures were just the beginning
from the looks of it any living thing
exposed to the Rays of scp-001 would
quickly dissolve into a horrible gooey
substance that would ooze towards other
organisms in an attempt to absorb them
into its biomass basically it was like a
zombie apocalypse straight out of an
Easy Bake Oven the Stardust Crusaders
had been passing through the city on
their globetrotting Adventure only to
find that morning had brought with it a
disaster the likes of which had never
been seen before by mid-afternoon when
the sun was highest in the sky most of
the people had already been converted
into slime monsters and those who fled
into the Shadows found themselves
relentlessly hunted down and absorbed
only the stand users of jotoros grew who
were already on the lookout for strange
happenings had been clever enough to
pick up on the situation immediately
they had been the subject of many
unusual Supernatural attacks over the
course of their Journey so the initial
anomalous effects of scp-001 seemed to
be another routine brush with an enemy
hey jotaro this has to be the effect of
an enemy stand right Joseph said what
are you stupid or something old man spag
Jean-Pierre ponref the Frenchman was
ever the impulsive one and he always
found something to complain about out
when a woman wasn't present he was
selectively polite one might say it was
fitting given the fact that his stand
silver Chariot took the form of a
sword-wielding knight and its reaction
speed was the fastest of any of the
Stardust Crusaders you think one Stan
could do all this polnerv was adamant
about making his point jotaro's fellow
High School classmate noriaki kakeon was
the next to speak honoref keep your
voice down we can't be sure it's not a
stand but either way those flesh
monsters are looking for us kakyon was
younger than polarath pretended to carry
himself with more composure this likely
had something to do with the fact that
hero fent green was the group's most
technical stand and often used for
reconnaissance what do you think of it
all kakian continued you're the expert
here Muhammad Abdul a fortune teller who
possessed a stand that controls fire
magicians read was often knowledgeable
about the supernatural a stand this
powerful would have to be limited in the
range it could affect Abdul said well we
have have to do is get further away from
this area then we'll see if this strange
sunlight Fades but what if the user is
following us Joseph interjected how will
we know we aren't putting more people at
risk Mr Joe Starr we can win this battle
without more information Abdul replied
your hyphen green has the longest range
send it to scout for a place outside of
the Stan's reach our stands shouldn't be
visible to those transformed humans and
the heat from the sunlight won't affect
something without mass friendly reminder
to those of you at home unfamiliar with
the properties of stands stands are
spectral entities formed from the soul
of the user and are essentially super
powered ghosts without physical presence
as such they won't be affected by
scp-001 the way a living thing would now
back to this Bizarre Adventure right
here off and green cocoon summoned his
stand and began threading hirofin
Green's long stretchy body throughout
the ruins as far as it could go the
young man concentrated looking through
the eye eyes of his stand as kakian and
his stands search for the end of the
anomalous effects of scp-001 polnerv
continued to complain as usual so we're
still not sure what's going on but from
what I've heard you're already calling
it a stand did I get that right afterl
ponref grumbled do you have any better
ideas
avdol said sternly Iggy barked Iggy the
last member of the Stardust Crusaders he
was a Boston Terrier who commanded a
sand manipulating stand known as the
fool Iggy didn't really have much to add
to the conversation but he liked to be
heard listen said Joseph joestar when I
was a younger man I actually did go head
to head with some terrifying beings who
might be able to turn people into
monsters like these but every single
time the sun was the enemy of those guys
nobody is interested in hearing your
stories right now old man jotaro chided
his grandfather meanwhile far from where
the Stardust Crusaders were hiding out
hierophant green was reaching the limits
of its effective range and seeing no
sign of an end to the anomalous effects
kakian was baffled could it be true that
the entire world had been affected by
the frightening ability of the sun now
that it was
scp-001 if that was true then the
apocalyptic Wasteland was more than just
the work of an enemy stand user this
would mean that the sun itself had
become I'm the enemy of all life kakin
wondered about his family back in Japan
would they manage to survive this
terrible catastrophe he couldn't help
but hope that there was some way out of
this utter Devastation even though the
information gathered by a stand told him
otherwise kakian withdrew hierophant
green and brought his companions up to
speed however hard it was to accept the
world as they knew it was Gone with the
Daybreak polnerv was beside himself in
sadness while Abdul and Joseph exchanged
a meaningful glance for once Iggy's bad
attitude subsided and the dog simply
whispered only jotaro remained
determined to carry on good grief would
you all get a hold of yourselves jotaro
said will remain human as long as we
aren't caught in that light so I'll use
star Platinum to Tunnel our way
underground jotaro's star Platinum was a
short-range stand but in terms of raw
power it was off the charts its punches
could easily tunnel through solid rock
and create a Subterranean passageway way
for the Crusaders to retreat to a safer
area attaboy jotaro Joseph exclaimed
we'll make our daring Escape mole style
jotro nodded and called star Platinum
shouting its signature Battle Cry of
star Platinum smashed through the earth
below instantly creating the entrance to
a tunnel at that exact moment every
flesh monster in the nearby vicinity
turned its attention towards the sound
the Sten users had to move quickly
because they would soon be completely
surrounded
oh my God shouted Joseph in his usual
way as a couple of Flesh monsters began
to enter the ruined building luckily
Paul norff and avdal sprung into action
and summoned silver Chariot and
magicians read to fend off the flesh
zombies silver Chariot delivered an
inescapably fast Fury of Sword strikes
to one of the monsters while magicians
read burned them away with its
Supernatural Flames the two men
high-fived had a job well done just then
the wall next to them burst open
revealing a new monster and caused the
sun's Rays to enter into the building's
interior with split-second intuition
avdal pushed Palmera further into the
Shadows the Frenchman tumbled backwards
into the whole jotoro maid and before he
could get his bearings he caught a
glimpse of avdal being absorbed into the
monster's Mass Abdul he cried out but it
was too late avdal was already starting
to show signs of transformation into an
ooze-like zombie himself the fortune
teller brief lived in deep and called
the name of his stand with determined
fervor magicians read before avdal could
be fully taken by the slime he unleashed
the totality of his Firepower on every
zombified life form within range its
destructive heat enhanced by the dryness
of the atmosphere avdal turned back to
his friends and gave them a heartfelt
thumbs up before he disappeared into the
Flames polnerv cried out for his friend
again with tears in his eyes but kaukin
and Joseph grabbed him and made their
way deeper into the tunnel as badass and
heroic as it was Abdul's sacrifice
wouldn't keep those hordes of monsters
at Bay for long hokaikan and Joseph
dragged a crying pulmonary through the
underground Escape round Joe throw and
Iggy were already at the front of the
group using a combination of star
platinum's digging ability and Iggy's
sand manipulation to stabilize the
tunnel the Stardust Crusaders were deep
beneath the surface of the Earth now so
a cave-in could be a real problem we
have to go back shrieked don't need your
help it's too late Paul rev Joseph said
with grim conviction Abdul is gone we we
don't know that for sure upon the ref
carried on let me go but kakin and
Joseph held on to polarev tightly and
continued to drag him down the
passageway hoping not to lose him to
this daytime nightmare as well on the
inside jotaro was shaken by the loss of
one of his companions but nobody would
have been able to tell by looking at his
stoic exterior he was solely focused on
keeping the tunnel expanding so that he
and the remaining Crusaders could
survive this ordeal together suddenly a
noise from the opposite end of the
passageway put the group on high alert
like a flood of liquefied horror the
flesh monsters had begun pouring
themselves into the pit and were now
moving towards the group inch by inch
oh no Joseph shouted he loosened his
grip on palmoreth and both of them
immediately booked it towards jotoro and
Iggy kakin however stood in place and
braced himself he didn't like it but he
knew what he had to do right now his
Stan had the ability to stop these
things but first he had to slow them
down Emerald Splash kakyun shouted
prompting herofin green to launch a
stream of concussive green gemstones
from its hands as planned the attack
slowed the Slime monsters down kakin was
then able to put the second part of his
plan into effect he identified what
appeared to be a face on the monster in
front and sent hierophant green to make
its way inside the creature's body this
was his Stan's most terrifying ability
and one [ __ ] in seldom used hirofin
green had the power to control the
bodies of other physical entities from
within once his stand had established
control kakin forced the massive ooze to
stop in place instantly plugging the
tunnel and preventing the rest of the
monsters from getting any closer how
long could he keep this up he didn't
know but because of herofin Green's
properties as a remote stand calcion was
able to run and rejoin Joe Toro and the
others at the front of the tunnel the
tether between himself and his stand was
stretching farther by the minute but he
dared not let his control of the oozing
entity slip lest he and his companions
suffer the same fate as afterl before
long jotaro felt a different sort of
surface at the front of the tunnel
rather than Earth it was brick with one
punch from Star Platinum he smashed
through and into what appeared to be an
abandoned subway station the power was
still on but most of the lights had
faded it was fortunate that there was no
natural sunlight in this place as
everyone's eyes adjusted to the light
the stand users crossed the tracks and
made their way onto the somewhat safer
area polnerv drifted over to the
magazine kiosk searching for signs of
anyone behind the counter there was
nobody here and Iggy soon helped himself
to some of the coffee flavored chewing
gum at the concession stand the dog
couldn't resist his favorite snack after
all jotro stood by the tracks as if
Waiting for a Train while Cochin did his
best to maintain his hold on the
monsters further behind them in the
tunnel with a bit of searching Joseph
found a large portable music player
designed for CDs also known as a Boombox
with the use of his divination focused
stand hermit purple Joseph created
purple thorny Vines which weave their
way into the wires of the device and
generated a psychic message hermit
purple could usually be counted on to
provide more detail about a situation
but its powers were limited by the
device used to gain the information in
this case the CD within the Boombox had
a copy of the Beatles famous 1969 album
Abbey Road so hermit purple's message to
Joseph came out as a garbled but oddly
appropriate rearrangement of the lyrics
to Here Comes the Sun little darling I
see their faces slowly melting little
darling it seems like you since it's
been all right here comes the sun
Here Comes the Sun and I say I feel I've
been slowly melting sun sun sun sun here
it comes oh my God Joseph said to
himself quietly just then kakin felt the
body that herofin green was controlling
give way apparently the pressure of so
many other ooze monsters had been too
much for it to hold back and now these
things were barreling down the tunnel
towards the Crusaders rather than
pulling herofin green back completely
kakin Unleashed his Emerald Splash over
and over again in an attempt to force a
cave-in but the creatures were too
resilient and their ooze-like structures
meant they could squeeze past mere rocks
in their path kakin told the rest of the
group that it was time to leave and as
if On Cue a train began to pull into the
station unfortunately the crazy train
pulled into the station with several
Cars full of ooze zombies ready to grab
the poor team and drag them into the sun
there was no way out but up the stairs
back into the sunlight they had done
everything possible to escape from as
polnerv jotaro Joseph and Iggy did their
best to fend off the attacking creatures
using their stands Cochin made one
last-ditch attempt to contain the
monsters he stretched here from Green
down to its most basic form a series of
long green fibrous strings and created a
net to ensnare the creatures while the
users could still seep its way through
its wiry form kakin rigged his stand to
set off an emerald Splash on every bit
of anomalous goo that made it past the
Nets defenses it was a sustainable and
effective wall against the monsters
using both the tensile string length of
the stand and its energy attacks to
effectively stymie their progress there
was only one problem in order to
maintain this Perfect Defense Cochin
would have to stay behind I'll hold them
go on without me kakin said
Joseph shouted as the rest of them ran
as fast as they could out of the subway
having effectively lost two members of
the group The Stardust Crusaders were
low in spirits looking up through the
subway exit they could see that they
would soon be in contact with the
sunlight meaning that even their
survival would become unlikely but
jotaro wasn't about to give in he
grabbed Iggy and held the dog out in
front of him alright Iggy it's now or
never other show us who can be a team
player or be the first to turn into one
of those blob Monsters Iggy struggled in
Joe throws grip but to Noah fail the dog
knew that jotoro was serious so in an
act of self-preservation that was
unusually generous of him Iggy used the
fool to stir up the sand on the ground
above into a gigantic Shady sand Dome
moments later he compressed it into a
compact Fortress of sand Iggy's Moving
Castle as it were no light could enter
this Fortress but because of the
granular nature of sand oxygen was
flowing freely the Stardust Crusaders
now had a method of travel in this world
torn apart by scp-001 of course there
was still the matter of dealing with the
flesh creatures outside even if the
Fortress of sand could move across the
surface without sunlight getting in the
surrounding oozes could still impede its
progress with the help of all three of
jotoro Joseph and paulnerev stands a
solution soon became clear Joseph would
use hermit purple on the sand to Divine
the location of any approaching threats
while jotaro and polnerv would Patrol
the outside of the miniaturized Fortress
with star platinum and silver Chariot
respectively that way whenever a flesh
creature got too close the two attack
type stands could unleash full force
barrages to knock them away the next
thing to do was for Iggy to increase the
speed of the sand construct by adding
Wheels to it it was like a gigantic sand
monster truck zooming through the ruins
with a platinum brawler and a silver
Knight repelling anything that came to
near once again gained enough velocity
with the fool Joseph used hermit purple
to discern the location of a bit of
rubble shaped conveniently like a ramp
the sand castle vaulted off the ramp and
into the air while Iggy augmented his
creation once again with a pair of
gigantic gliding wings now they were
soaring out of the reach of the flesh
monsters Joseph and paulnerev shared
sympathies over the loss of their two
important friends avdal and cowken had
both bravely given themselves to protect
the team and none of the Crusaders would
be here if it wasn't for them jotaro
focused on helping Iggy pilot the sand
glider using star Platinum to kick the
ground whenever the vehicle got too low
nobody was sure what they would
encounter next in the Daybreak or what
Bizarre Adventures were yet to unfold
but they had each other and for now that
was enough now go check out I survived
100 days of scp-001 when day breaks
here's what happened and scp-001 when
day breaks tail hour by hour for more
horrifying when day breaks action